please welcome the Reuben reports Dave
Rubin and the one and only Richard
Dawkins
thank you very much doctor were you
looking for the protesters was that it
they never come I don't know one office
yeah as far as I know we're just with a
bunch of bright New Yorkers and there
were no protests outside is that kind of
disappointing these days in a bit yes
we could probably rile them up we'll see
what we could do I so there's a time
this first off is an absolute thrill and
honor for me I've been trying to get you
on my show since before I had a show I
think and I thought the right way to
start would be a little bit about the
free speech space and the fake news
space and that whole thing yesterday
you were supposed to be speaking at
Berkeley you did not speak at Berkeley
they D platformed you that's that's a
new phrase this has happened to you
before what do you make of what's going
on doesn't think it was yesterday but
anyway all right as I was D platformed
it did happen before I was d platformed
by a conference in New York State and
they then re platformed me again two
weeks later with a very gracious apology
and invited me back and they got it all
wrong which of course they had but I
couldn't go unfortunately um so that
this had happened before and the one in
Berkeley that was that was to have
happened I think a couple of days time
this is a radio station which I used to
love when I lived in Berkeley I lived
there for two years and it would be this
was a sort of liberal beacon at a time
in the late sixties when Berkeley was
the home of free speech free speech
moves was 1963 how have the mighty
fallen Berkeley the home of free speech
now the home of suppression of free
speech and that's very sad to me because
I love the place I'd I always have loved
the place and the less said about it the
better really yeah all right well we'll
do science and you want to do science
yeah I'll ask you one other thing on
that what can you give me one other and
then we'll go right to decide when this
happens do you ever have a moment where
you go house
something really has beard off the path
here not just yes in in politics but in
society as a whole that we really lost
something that is so important to us I
think we really have I mean this is the
minor just a minor episode but there in
a large number of cases where university
campuses have been protests to prevented
people from going to speak at
universities because they just don't
like what they think they're going to
hear and it's really sad when you think
that a university of all places is the
place where ideas should be added and
exchanged and disputed and argued over
go on argue that's what in the
university is for there's sort of soft
sappy inability to take something that
you find offensive and hurtful it's
pathetic it's contemptible not the bar
is worthy right there and we feel this
creeping into the hard sciences right I
mean to blend this to your book right
now and talk about rationality it was
one thing when some of this stuff was
happening with the social sciences but
now we see it with the hard sciences
which i think has a lot of people really
shocked I'm not sure why you say hard
sciences I mean the fact that I happen
to be a scientist that that's it's not
scientists who are doing the protesting
it's I don't know it is but it's but I
hope it's not scientists no no not the
scientists it's the students that are
upset about ideas have shifted from just
going after sociology it usually is
because they're it offends their
sociological sensibilities and it
usually I don't think anybody has
protested about somebody coming and
talking about quantum theory yet react
yeah that'll be the day
so the book is called science in the
soul and when they when they send me the
copy I mean the title right there I mean
you you're a well-known atheist
science in the soul how can it be well
there's that there's a chapter about
killing the soul 50 years on yeah
which which begins with think I just saw
just now it begins with a definition of
soul two different definitions and one
of them is the immortal soul the
religious soul which is the one that's
going to be killed right it's okay you
don't have to bother back yes I mean
I've defined so the Oxford English
Dictionary soul one like what I call
soul one is the spiritual part of man
regarded as surviving after death and
the susceptible of happiness or misery
in a future state that's the one we're
going to kill so two is intellectual or
spiritual power high development of the
mental faculties also in some what we
can sense deep feeling sensitivity the
feet of the emotions feelings or
sentiments the emotional part of man's
nature and I think that you can be
emotional about you can be poetic
certainly about science so Carl Sagan
Albert Einstein many scientists have
West soulful spiritual about the beauty
of the world from a scientific point of
view I wrote a book myself called I'm
reading the rainbow which was an attempt
to rebut John Keats who complained about
Newton he thought Newton had spoiled the
poetry of the rainbow by explaining it
whereas obviously what I think is that
you it becomes more poetic not less if
you understand about what what's causing
all this beauty and the worldís is full
of beauty it's beautiful that we can
understand it it's beautiful that we who
have evolved on this rock orbiting with
some four billion years of evolution as
led to our having a brain and nervous
system it's big enough to understand
where we came from why we're here how
big the universe is how old the universe
is how it's going to end we now know all
that it isn't that wonderful in that
beautiful can't you feel spiritual self
all about that you know what I mean by
starting
what about the people that do a little
bit of part 1 there of the the first
definition that they accept all the
things that you just said and they are
rational and believe in science and all
that but also have a piece that that
can't be explained that that they
themselves can yes I'm going
I'm reminded of a lovely story by
Douglas Adams as a great hero of mine he
told a story of a man who didn't
understand how television worked and he
thought there must be little men inside
the television who were sort of moving
the images around and so an engineer sat
him down and explained to him about
radio waves and about amplifiers and
about scanlines and and how they were
modulated by the radio waves and how
them squeeze it on yeah yeah that makes
sense
yes I see I understand I understand how
television works except there are just a
few little men in there aren't there
then oh I think I think it all or none
you've got got to go the whole hog yeah
rationality which really is what this
yeah book is about we don't seem to have
much of it right now I'm not even
talking we can put the colleges aside
and all that just the general level of
discourse we were talking in the in the
green room a little bit about Twitter
you can poo you know that the the way we
communicate right now has very little to
do with the rational mind do you think
yes and you mentioned Twitter I mean
that is a problem as it with the
anonymity I sometimes think when I read
a Twitter that lovely quote from George
Carlin who said think how stupid the
average person is and now reflect that
50% or even stupid laugh
I I had a tweet which is a quote from
from the book it's from a chapter which
is a satire a sarcastic satire of Tony
Blair the former British prime minister
who started a foundation for the
promulgation of religious faith and my
SATA said of course we are going to
encourage Sharia law but only on a
strictly voluntary basis only for this
only for those whose husbands and
fathers agree well and you'd be amazed
how many people thought that didn't get
the sarcasm I thought I was actually
when advocating Sharia law yeah but for
a guy with your brain that's a pretty
big brain in there you you're looking at
these comments and these people are
responding that that's got to be
something that's pretty depressing
hahaha yes
well I'm accused of being an elitist and
and I suppose I probably am I mean that
um do we need more of that though a
little a little internet really when you
said with it's a bad time it's only a
bad time for about half I mean the
United States is the greatest scientific
country in the world has the greatest
scientists in the world greatest
intellectuals in the world what's
amazing is that this country manages to
do so well in spite of the Incubus fees
the burden the other 50%
dragging you down almost splitting the
country into two species are sometimes
dated
none of these people here though I visit
America often and and I love coming here
and I think yesterday was the first time
I've ever actually met a trump voter I
mean they must be out there but where
are they out of that interaction go a
Trump voter and Richard on twit with a
woman on Fox News she was interviewing
me on Fox News and it was last night
yeah Laura something Ingram was ill
orient Laura Ingraham he was actually
very nice and and the interview went
went well but but she but I knew she was
a trauma boater because she was yelling
at some flee immediately before me and
on the phone on my television yeah the
yelling there's a lot of yelling these
days people don't go scream - yelling
simultaneously so that you can't hear a
word either of them is saying that seems
to be the name of the game so how do we
start getting rationality and science
back how do we sort of pull back from
this strange precipice that we seem to
be out where everyone is yelling I'm not
known for my skill politician as a
diplomat I mean I tend to just put it
out there and attacked once by in a very
genial way you can imagine my Neil
deGrasse Tyson who said you just put it
out there and that's not persuasion
that's just
that's just putting it out there and I'm
afraid that is what I do I mean I write
books and people can read them if they
want to and if they don't they don't
have to rather like the editor of New
Scientist I once quoted Alan Anderson
who he was a very successful editor of
New Scientist magazine and I asked him
once in public what is your policy at an
editor of New Scientist and he said our
policy at New Scientist is science is
interesting and you don't agree you can
[ __ ] off well that's as Neil deGrasse
Tyson would say that is that no way to
persuade anybody off and what it gets
the point across yes kind of yeah so
perhaps being congenial isn't always the
best way to get me guys I like to think
I'm congenial but I mean I think when
people meet me face-to-face they find me
quite quite polite I think have a
different reputation in writing about my
job I that is what I do what do you
think the best way to get young people
involved in sciences well there are two
schools of thought about this and I've
be interested in both of since I was
professor of public understanding of
science one way is what I call slightly
disparagingly the nonstick frying pan
approach if you're talking about say the
space program and why one might advocate
the space program the nonstick frying
pan approach is to say it useful and I
so kind of satirized it by the non-stick
frying pan is a spinoff from the space
program something about the heat shield
and that is supposed by some people to
be a good way to interest people in size
to bring it down to earth to make it
relevant to everyday life relevant to
the kitchen
and I don't think that's very it my way
is the more the Carl Sagan approach
which is the inspiring poetic look at
the Stars look at the galaxies think how
far away they are reflect when you look
at a star you're looking at it
a million years ago ten million years
ago you're looking at the Sun eight
minutes ago I mean things like that the
the poetic beauty of Carl Sagan's
language that's my way though the way I
advocate for interesting people in size
over their children or not the lovely
children's book I'm sorry I can't
remember the author or the title who's
trying to get across P so the sheer
scale of the universe so he says get a
soccer ball and put it in the middle of
the playing field at the school and then
walk 20 paces away and put down I forget
what it is I think maybe a pinhead
that's the earth 20 paces away to scale
and then walk again it might be a
hundred yards or some math would be
it'll be more and then put down a
ping-pong ball and that's Jupiter now
the nearest star to the Sun Proxima
Centauri I pick up another soccer ball
and walk 2,000 miles that's the nearest
star well that I regard is a good way
together and I've done that with
children they're absolutely riveted they
love that you know they love that I find
that so much better than the nonstick
frying pan approach or the practical
Bunsen burner approach where everything
you do you have to sort of do an
experiment you have to see you have to
piece test tube or something I think
it's obviously important that we need
scientists we need to train people to be
scientists we also need to bring science
into the culture and make science
fascinating in the same way that art or
music is aesthetically pleasing and that
that's more the way that appeals to me
yeah do you sense with all the sort of
political upheaval in America in the
world the conversations are having the
yelling the 10:00 cable box people all
screaming at each other it's saying that
there's an interesting and unique
opportunity right now I've been saying
on my show for a while that I sense
that there's fertile ground actually for
ideas right now because people are
really a ting everything well that's an
optimistic thought you know yes let's
hope you're right I'm not quite sure how
I get a word in edgeways with the
yelling that's but yeah but have you
noticed time times throughout your life
where there were there were suddenly
fertile ground even if it came from
reasons that you were unhappy with or
that you know shouldn't have happened
that that's where ideas then start to
flourish well maybe I can't give any
particular examples do you have a do
have example to that I don't I just said
it on the show and people kind of liked
it and then I I just have a sense I have
a sense when I talk to people when I
interview people right now but that
everyone is really a ting sort of
everything their their political beliefs
you know I just sense that people are
willing to at least explore ideas where
maybe two years ago yes there's a lot of
yelling but I sense that there's some
movement there well let's hope you're
right let's roll up our sleeves and get
down to it good yeah we should yeah yeah
who right now is besides you is doing
some great work in the in the scientific
field right now oh goodness and we
didn't prepare any of these questions no
um well I mean I'm I'm fascinated by
molecular genetics it's not a field but
I mean I mean but it's clearly
revolutionizing biology it's turning
biology into a branch of computer
science it's digital now that's been
clear really ever since Watson and Crick
is becoming more and more utterly
totally digital and the CRISPR technique
of Jennifer Doudna for example I mean
she's clearly a real live wire in in
this field ancient DNA I'm fascinated by
that by the use of DNA techniques to
look at archaeology to look at human
ancestry to look at to get the DNA from
a woolly mammoth
and maybe even closer mammoths we can
bring it back to life bring back in the
and earth all human it worked out well
in Jurassic Park right well that that
was going back along a lot so that's a
brilliant plot I mean the idea of taking
insects embalmed in amber and getting
blood does it was a the last blood meal
of a mosquito taken from a dinosaur what
a lovely idea that was Michael Crichton
wasn't it yet Michael Crichton's idea
unfortunately it's not feasible but it's
but it's beautiful and that that's the
kind of thing that one ought to be able
to do but to bring back Silas Silas the
Tasmanian wolf to bring back woolly
mammoths to bring back the undertale'
human Steve Gould said that was the most
immoral thing he could imagine but I
can't see what I have well I can I can
sort of see objections to it faster I
think the objection the more objection
to it would be something like that the
that the the person concern would be
such a newsworthy freak show that it
would be cruel to fritter to that
individual I mean that I do think would
be the moral consideration yeah is that
just the sacrifice that has to be made
for science well I'm not sure I want to
make it but but but but that that's the
scale of the of the moral question that
I think this where he clearly thought it
was a much bigger thing than that yeah
where do you draw the line on those
moral questions in general not
necessarily about that well I don't for
me that the big question is does it does
it cause suffering and so the the in
this case the suffering would would be
of an individual being a sort of freak
show as I said in something like the
abortion debate for me the important
thing is can it suffer or who is
suffering and a embryo that is too young
to have a nervous system cannot suffer
and so the sort of absolutist morality
that says all human life is sacred I
have no time for I only have try
morality that is concerned with actual
paint and eyelashes or fear or other
forms of suffering yeah
so you bring up morality I've had it on
my show I have believers and
non-believers and atheists and people of
the cloth and all sorts of people and
we've had some interesting debates about
morality and religion how do you get
your morality your and I ask you that I
mean your personal around well I think I
get it from the same way most people get
it from a kind of I guess the protesters
are here they're knocking knocking
politely um maybe it's not an like that
could be God knocking at Eva's mother
values of all the carpenter after all
well I think that morality needs to be
intelligently designed as opposed to
laid down in some holy book and I saw a
wonderful jazz picture yesterday I think
it was which was a picture of the Bible
labeled the goat herders Guide to the
galaxy and yes intelligent design
we don't want intelligent design as an
explanation for our existence you've got
Darwinism for that but we do need
intelligent design for morality we do
not get we should not and do not get our
morality from holy books we clearly
don't if we did we would be stoning
adulterers to death and stoning people
for breaking the Sabbath and things like
that we do get our morality from moral
philosophy from the legal court cases
from parliamentary discussions from just
general talk in the air in the moral
values that we have in the 21st century
are palpably different from those not
just not even 100 years ago 50 years ago
the the changes that feminism has
wrought for example in the way they use
language the way we could no longer get
away with the phrase like one-man
one-vote we don't do that anymore we've
had our consciousness raised if you go
back and read well think that women only
got the vote in I forget where it was in
America's I'm having the 1920s maybe was
it it was roughly then in Britain I
think in Switzerland I think 1970s so
we're moving on all the time we've given
up slavery we've given up torturing
animals for fun except in Spain
and there's what I call the shifting
moral zeitgeist which is going on all
the time when you can see it in the way
people talk in conversation in novels
and all sorts of things and it changes
faster even than by the century by
century changes decade by decade if you
think about the way warfare was
conducted in the middle of the 20th
century the Second World War
you have bombers going over the cities
of Coventry and Dresden say nothing of
Hiroshima and Nagasaki which were
killing slaughtering civilians by the
thousands and nowadays in modern warfare
if civilians get killed it's a matter
for apology well it's bad that they
still get killed is that any might still
get killed but so it's a big change it's
a big improvement we are changing all
the time in the right direction Steven
Pinker's better angels of our nature
shows this historically over a very long
period we are getting better and it has
nothing to do with religion it has to do
with some mysterious change of what's in
the air almost and when I don't mean
that in a mystical way it's no doubt of
the some of things like as I say moral
philosophy general conversation
journalism law parliamentary debate and
so on which all come together to move
the move the zeitgeist on and no doubt
that that will that will continue and so
that's where I get my morality from it's
where you get your morality from and
even if you're religious you don't
actually get your morality from the Ten
Commandments I mean the idea that we'd
get a morality for the Ten Commandments
Christopher Hitchens satirizes rather
well when he when he said for one thing
thou shalt not kill is it about the only
one with him c'mon within a religious
person actually knows and Christopher
satirize it by saying Moses came down
from the mountain with his tablets and
said thou shalt not kill thou shalt not
kill
we never thought of that
you you dedicated the book to
Christopher yes I I think almost every
day I at some point during the day I
think man I wish we had Hitchens and
Carlin those those are the two for me
that I wish I read yes do you wish you
had more public allies in these fights
yes I mean it's it's the the loss of
Christopher was a huge tragedies 11
personal tragedy obviously but also
tragedy for intellectual life and I
dedicated the book to him the last
chapter of the book is the speech that I
made in his honor shortly before he died
very shortly before he died and I ended
up ended the book which it had dedicated
to him as I say reverting to the the
word soul and saying about Christopher
this encrypted warrior for truth this
cultured courteous citizen of the world
this devastating coruscating enemy of
lies and camped well maybe he has no
immortal soul none of us has but in the
only meaning of the words that make any
that makes any sense
the soul of Christopher Hitchens is
among the Immortals
his dedication to truth is the part and
your dedication to truth we seem to be
picking our own truths these days
there's this the idea of fake news we
cater ideas to ourselves yes that just
reinforced the things that we already
believe
so I'll ask that in two parts first
where do you get your news Oh mostly
from the internet and also from I take
the Guardian in in Britain and I log in
to the New York Times and CNN and BBC
and the independence but on the question
of fake news it's particularly bad just
at the moment in this political
atmosphere and and when we have in this
country a president who relies so much
he doesn't even know his lying he's just
a chronic liar and that of course is
terrible but I think also there's been a
longer term atmosphere of devaluing of
objective truth in favor of a kind of
subjective emotional my truth is not the
same as your truth well it's true for me
even if it is not true for you my
opinion is what matters never mind about
whether it's true or not and that he
gets I think even some encouragement
from certain academic disciplines which
had begun a whispering campaign against
the values of objective truth and I
think that this is where science really
comes into its own science is about
objective truth it's not about opinion
it's not about a subject if your truth
is different from my truthful I'm
entitled to my Cruz and you're entitled
to yours and and that is anathema to the
scientific spirit do i do feel
passionately about that yeah do you feel
that that sort of postmodern thinking
that we all sort of have our own truths
that that actually is the biggest
threat to science or do you look at
someone like Trump or or just any other
leader out there that that either is
cutting funding designs or whatever I
mean trumpism is a more immediate threat
but the other maybe more insidious one
in the long in the long term no I want
to go back to to religion for a moment
between one of the one of the things
that I find people are struggling with
the most and I know you've talked about
a lot is separating ideas from people
yes that we should be able to criticize
ideas and that doesn't mean you're
criticizing everyone that prescribes
necessarily to all of those ideas or
that we all pick and choose ideas and
have weak spots and blind spot can you
talk a little bit about ideas where yes
absolutely right and there's no doubt
about it that that many people identify
with their ideas religious ideas
especially so much I thought it was
chasing a motto no no do a better job
that seems the audience questions just
kidding good that's good um there is a
tendency for people I think especially
religious people to identify so strongly
with their ideas of the religious ideas
that they think that to criticize there
are their religious ideas criticize
their beliefs is tantamount to insulting
them personally tantamount to saying you
bought an ugly face and this is so wrong
and it's so so retrograde because you
ideas are there to be criticized you
must be able to defend your ideas if
they're any good then you should say I
believe this because I believe it's
because so and so because x y&z you
cannot just just show today oh you've
insulted me you've you've mortally
offended me by criticizing my ideas I
again to quote Christopher Hitchens he
said you're offended by what I've just
said I'm still waiting to hear your
point
[Laughter]
Stephen Fry said it even more Stephen
Fry who's such a sweetheart that it's
such a gentle darling man said you're
offended well so [ __ ] what your ideas
are not you you are a person and I will
not offend you as a person I will not I
will not insult you as a person but I
will criticize your ideas
I love the quotation from the British
journalist Johann Hari who said I
respect you as a person too much to
respect your ridiculous ideas here a lot
of people have trouble getting this
though right I mean they say I
definitely do yeah
this has got you in hot water on social
media and things because there you know
there's a certain set of ideas right now
which which you do openly criticize each
trouble and another thing I think is is
that some people find clarity
threatening another thing is that I tend
to use words precisely as they're
defined at the dictionary and whereas
other people interpret those words
according to how they make them feel and
so most an example of that I won't have
one only yesterday I think um that's
what it was but an earlier example was
that I once wrote in The New York Times
that anybody who does not believe in
evolution is either ignorant stupid or
insane now that if you think about it is
actually a statement of sober fact it
really is it really is because but by
far the most important one of those
three ignorant stupid or insane is
ignorant and we are all ignorant of many
things as I said diapers I said
somewhere I'm ignorant of baseball and
Polynesian nose flutes
and everybody's ignorant of most things
I'm ignorant of most things that there
are to be to be known it's not an insult
it's a statement of fact anybody who
doesn't believe in evolution is probably
ignorant that's not an insult just a
simple statement of fact but people
don't hear it as a statement of fact you
tell them I'll go look it up in the
dictionary it's not an insult it just
means you don't know and somebody who
doesn't believe in you in evolution
they could be stupid or insane but it's
much more likely that they just don't
know in the other words they're ignorant
and it's up to us as scientists to do
something about it and teach them well
you find it refreshing when people say I
don't know just that simple phrase yes I
mean that that's right yes I do and I
say it myself a lot sass proceeds by
people not not knowing and wanting to
know trying to do something about it I
would be remiss I'm going to get to the
audience questions but if having you
here as a big sci-fi guy would talk to
me a little bit about AI and where you
think this is going to take us and will
it make us evolve differently faster
well I'm not try to use the word evolve
but it could be that but you guys I
think AIS I'm committed to them to the
view philosophically that as a
philosophical naturalist that there's
nothing in our brain that isn't governed
governed by the laws of physics and so
in principle it must be possible to
simulate everything that a brain does in
silico and so in principle it must be
possible to make robots that are capable
doing everything that he was going to do
and if some people are very alarmed at
that idea that they'll take our jobs and
maybe even get rid of us because we
won't be needed anymore and as you say
this is science fiction
moment it sounds fiction that has to be
taken seriously like all good science
fiction
and there are people like Elon Musk and
Stephen Hawking who are seriously
worried about it and you have to listen
to them they're highly intelligent
geniuses both of them so I I'm part of
me is rather excited by the idea as a
scientist I'm intrigued by the idea that
building computing machines that a caper
doing what humans can do will help us to
understand how we work and will solve
some of the great philosophical
questions that remain on the other hand
if they really did suppress us because
we're not needed that's clearly
something to be a bit worried about it
could be that they make a much better
job of running the world well than we do
and since I think I'm committed to the
view that they must be capable of
emotions like being happy they might
increase the sum of I would say human
happiness to some of sentient being
happiness in the world so it might not
be all bad I'll take that as hopeful
that yeah I'll take that all right let's
let's jump into audience questions I
heard you say backstage you had no rules
so people could submit anything and I
shuffle them a little bit here so I'm
just going to go anywhere you believe
Darwin's theory of evolution is the only
theory that can't account adequately for
the phenomenon of life why only well
that's very interesting that there is a
chapter in the book or universal
domination which which advocates exactly
that point of view
Darwinism means that for selection
evolution by natural selection
not all evolution is governed by natural
selection even here plenty of evolution
is random with respect to natural
selection is random drift
but adaptive evolution the evolution in
the direction of improvement getting
better doing something like getting
better at flying or seeing
swimming or digging or climbing or
subpool thinking that is what natural
selection is extremely good at doing and
no other theory so far has ever been
proposed that can do that the only one
remotely competitive is Lamarckism which
is the combination of the inheritance of
acquired characteristics plus the
principle abuse and disuse use and
disuse means the more you use a bit of
yourself the bigger it gets and this is
true of muscles for example the more red
that's what training is all about and
more you use certain muscles the bigger
they get if you couple that with the
principle of inheritance of acquired
characteristics somebody who goes to the
gym and builds up muscles then has a
child with with a tendency to develop
bigger muscles that would be Lamarckian
evolution and what I argue in the
chapter is that although it works for
muscles it doesn't work for the vast
majority it cannot work for the vast
majority of adaptations things like eyes
for example which get better at seeing
there's no possible way in which simply
seeing makes your eyes better at it
lenses though become clearer because
photons wash through them you don't
develop an iris diaphragm to open and
shut to let in them the right amount of
light just just by simply exercise
natural selection does that effortlessly
natural selection does any improvement
in the body anywhere no matter how deep
you're buried in the biochemistry of the
cells if it's an improvement it improves
the chance of the animal surviving and
reproducing natural selection will grab
it and will build it in to future
generations natural selection can
produce any kind of improvement you can
imagine Lamarckism simply cannot do it
so I dispute that claim has been made by
various biologists that says Lamarckism
is a fine theory it might work on other
planets it just happens not to work on
this planet
because we don't have inheritance of
acquired characteristics that's wrong
even on a planet where you had
inheritance of acquired characteristics
you could not get complex adaptation
like eyes and ears by and brains even by
Lamarckian means so I go in the chapter
I go through only all the alternatives
that have ever been suggested and show
not only that they don't work but they
cannot work it couldn't work so there
remains the possibility that there's
some theory nobody's thought of and that
I cannot rule that out all I can do is
put my shirt on me I would bet a large
sum that if you if life is ever
discovered on other planets I would bet
everything I have that it will be it
will be Darwinian life in some sense it
wouldn't be in detailed it wouldn't be
similar I'm it wouldn't be the same it
would be similar there would have to be
some sort of genetics but it might not
be DNA that that kind of thing it seems
you connect atheism with acceptance of
the theory of evolution can't atheism
stand alone without the slightest nod to
evolution as if the theory was never
proposed ho goodness I doubt that
because we've got this stupendous
problem of explaining our existence when
I just am in existence of all living
things anybody who thinks that
underestimates the colossal
improbability of a living organism in
think about any living organism you like
but but just take a bird for example
it's a beautifully constructed machine
that can fly and walk and peck and
reproduce highly complicated machinery
devastatingly complicated which is
everything is geared to this one task of
surviving and reproducing in the
particular way that birds do it fish
there isn't another way monkeys there is
another way to to
abandon that and say I'm still an
atheist would be a very very hard thing
to do
I once had an argument with an eminent
philosopher he's not dead so I can
mention him a jair sir Alfred heir and I
said be very hard to be an atheist
before Darwin and he said why what's the
problem and I wrote a book actually to
try to explain to him we called the
blind watchmaker to explain to him what
the problem was I think and you just
simply you if you think that you just
don't get what enormous ly complicated
thing a living organism is let alone the
entire panoply of life I'll throw a
bonus one in off that which is I think I
heard you partially answer this with Sam
Harris in LA a couple months ago but
when you had your stroke about about a
year ago did it challenge any of your
beliefs or a lack of beliefs no it it it
it reinforced my faith in scientific
medicine I was very well treated in you
didn't go to a shaman no some of you may
read Dan Bennett's magnificent article
called thank goodness which he wrote
after he was when he was recovering from
a very very serious heart problem when
he very very nearly died and he said
that there's people had written to him
saying they were praying for him and
things like that so he replied and did
you also sacrifice a goat but he then
went on no actually I think he said he
was too polite to get that but that's my
reply but you then I don't say what I do
want to thank is is is not not thank God
I want to thank the surgeons who worked
on me for eight hours the man who
invented the electroencephalogram the
the man who invented the MRI scanner the
anesthetist all the nurses the people in
the laundry who coped with my
blood-stained sheets
he gave a great list of people that he
that he sacked it's a wonderful essay I
recommend you read the score thank
goodness google it well I'm glad you
mentioned Dan Dennett because I think
this is partly related to some of some
of the work he does do you believe that
quantum physics allows for the
possibility of free will namely physics
is not necessarily deterministic well
the principle of indeterminacy has been
the Heisenberg principle has been widely
misunderstood as being a kind of get out
and give give us give us free will I
mean I I hate the free will question I
must confess because I'm not a
philosopher and I I've read some of the
stuff on it that I'm not good at
answering the question I rather tend to
revert to Christopher Hitchens his
answer to the question do you believe in
free will I have no choice sssss
I know which question I'm going to do
last so I'm going to put that one there
how do you evaluate the contradiction
between capitalism's need for scientific
development on one hand and its
insatiable drive for competition and
profit that interestingly seems to cling
to mystification and religious thinking
for its cover that is a loaded question
if I have ever heard one
well nothing like it's loaded with
complication that name yeah why don't
you feel that one
you guys could talk amongst yourselves
for a moment capitalism a capitalism is
need for scientific developments on the
one hand and its insatiable drive for
competition and profit so it's a it's a
it's a contradiction between the need
for scientific development on the 1 and
capitalism needs scientific development
on the one hand on the other hand that
have an insatiable drive for competition
and profit um which if the questioner
thinks is incompatible with scientific
development whoever wrote this question
is having the moment of their life right
now Richard Dawkins examining my
question seems to cling to misstate
mystification religious thinking for its
cover drive for competition and profit I
don't get why competition and profit the
driver computer and profit seems to
cling to mystification and religious
thinking for its cover I think the
author of this question has written a
book about this which I would be
interested to read but for the moment I
don't
peridot fair enough flip that one over
there we touched on this a little bit at
the beginning if you want kids
interested in science teach how we came
from fish not lived in one so what do
you need - yeah but I like that where
you so what do you need to do to make
the theory of evolution the law of
evolution cosmetics can have a doctor
approved cosmetics can be doctor
approved can't scientists have the word
law approved - yes I like that I'm not
sure I can I'm still keen on the word
law in this case I just rather use the
word fact evolution is a fact we must
stop calling it a theory because it just
simply misleads people so the current
Orthodox way to handle this is to say
scientists use the word theory in a
different way from laypeople but that
just doesn't seem to work we can't get
across and it's only partially true
because scientists do use the word
theory as a synonym for hypothesis as
well and so although it is true that it
that something like the the theory of
gravity is a is not just a hypothesis
that might be true it might be false
nevertheless scientists do use the word
theory to mean something that is
tentative and might be wrong might be
right so I want to stop calling
evolution a theory just stop it that was
a lovely sketch by who's that comedian
who doesn't tell us who bob bob newhart
he plays a psychiatrist and he has a
woman who comes to him because she's has
a morbid fear of being buried alive in a
box and he and so he says well it's
gonna cost you five dollars I want you
to listen very carefully to the
following - I just say two words I want
you to take very careful Road so she
gets ready you stop it
so we're going to stop calling evolution
a theory evolution is a fact Michel Roux
said it's a fact fact fact it's a fact
that is established as surely as
securely as any fact in science law I'm
not so sure I call it a law it I think
that going to confuse people in other
ways I have used it the word law in this
context in my chapter in the book on
Universal Darwinism which I mentioned
earlier I think I said something like
Darwinism Darwinian natural selection
may turn out to have the same universal
lawful properties as the great laws of
physics physicists are committed to the
view that the laws of physics apply all
over the universe so I didn't mind using
the word laws there but I think it's
confusing to say it's not a theory it's
a law I'd rather say it's a fact it's a
fact that we observe it's a fact we
understand all right well first up I
know you're going to be taking some time
to sign copies of your book which came
out in the United States today today
that's right big enough so Richard we'll
be doing that after and I thought this
would be an appropriate one to end on
Richard how do I respond to a friend
when she says quote everything is good
or bad energy
she says bananas are bad energy so don't
eat them
putting bananas aside for a second
good or bad energy is there such thing
as good or bad energy what do you do
I wonder if a friend is here her energy
is one of those much misused words it
has a precise meaning the capacity to do
work and it's important concept in
physics it is misused horribly by
mystics and charlatans who are all the
time trying to solve balance your energy
is it balance your chakras and I think
things like like that if you divide the
word into work the things that have good
energy and bad energy then the kind of
thing I can say is you're simply
misusing the word energy and to be
slightly more unkind I would say
bollocks well give it up for Richard ah
who's everybody
[Applause]